Este es el edificio de la gobernación de
gersón que en las últimas semanas ha
sido ha tocado en dos oportunidades la
última hace cinco días y muestra una de
las grandes paradojas de esta ciudad una
de las primeras de Ucrania y la gran
capital de provincia la única que cayó
en control de las fuerzas rusas después
de esa invasión a gran escala el 24 de
febrero del año pasado aquí llegaron las
fuerzas de Moscú el primero de marzo y
tuvieron bajo control la ciudad durante
ocho meses todo creando un reino de
terror hasta que lograron retirarse
después de ocho meses cuando las fuerzas
ucranianas pusieron presión y ella se
retiraron no sin antes crear gran terror
desde entonces después de un periodo de
diez días donde la población vivió
felizmente hacían fiestas aquí en la
Plaza de la ciudad empezaron a atacarla
sistemáticamente con misiles y con
bombardeos desde el otro del río donde
se encuentran actualmente el frente de
batalla es muy pequeño solamente son
entre 800 metros y un kilómetro del río
que lo separa y desde allá atacan
constantemente la ciudad lo que ha hecho
que muchas de la población que había
regresado que estaba feliz de la ciudad
sube la liberada ha tenido que irse de
nuevo actualmente de los
365.000 habitantes que vivían aquí antes
de la guerra ahora solamente viven
60.000 y en condiciones algunos bastante
difíciles porque los sectores que están
al lado del río todavía no solamente son
atacados constantemente sino que tienen
problemas de Electricidad y de agua